des tables rondes pour mieux comprendre
l'enjeu des véhicules autonomes à
l'horizon 2035 ce marché devrait
représenter une manne financière de 900
milliards d'euros par an malgré ce
chiffre plusieurs paramètres freinent
son développement en france on a
énormément de start up en amande
entreprises qui sont à la pointe là
dessus mais malheureusement on n'arrive
pas à passer à l'échelle industrielle
le deuxième c'est le frein cognitif on
remarque aujourd'hui en france en fait
que la plupart des conducteurs et la
plupart des usagers sont pas encore
prêts en fait embrasser cette
technologie pourquoi parce qu'en fait
tout simplement on a peur parce qu'on ne
la connais pas le troisième c'est le
frein politique
vu que le véhicule autonome comme tout
autre véhicule présente un risque même
si je rappelle que la 80e on estime qu'à
90% des accidents sur la route qui
peuvent être évités grâce à cette
technologie là cette conférence était
organisée au sein du campus des services
de l'automobile et de la mobilité à
guyancourt
plusieurs thématiques ont été abordées
comme l'impact sur l'emploi
il a à ce jour à 20000 emplois dédiés
jus dans ce secteur d'activités saint
quentin en yvelines et on désire qu'une
chose c'est qu'évidemment ailier des
véhicules autonomes sur le territoire
ces tables rondes elles ont pour
vocation aussi à des silos t entre les
opérateurs
les constructeurs les collectivités les
instituts de recherche donc donc je
pense que la suite majeur c'est de
contribuer à favoriser un écosystème en
mouvement vers des nouveaux services de
mobilité innovants et utiles
il y a deux mois le gouvernement
français présenté un plan pour le
développement des véhicules autonomes
d'ici à 2022 16 nouvelles
expérimentations sont prévues un peu
partout en france